good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight like a lot of actors
matt damon has a weakness for silly
fashionable politics otherwise he seems
like a decent enough guy certainly by
the standards of the world he lives in
in the business where stars often behave
like demanding children the place where
Harvey Weinstein was long considered a
moral leader Matt Damon stands out he's
apparently well-liked by just about
everybody he deals with he gives
generously the charities been married to
the same woman for a dozen years they're
raising four daughters no one's ever
even accused him of sexual misconduct
but suddenly that doesn't matter Matt
Damon's career is now in jeopardy more
than 20,000 people have signed a
petition calling for producers to cut
Damon from his latest film that movies
already been shot but the petition
demands that any evidence of his voice
or image be removed from the film in the
editing booth other people are saying
Damon ought to be denied future film
roles and he may well be denied those
roles what does that lead Matt Damon due
to so thoroughly destroy his reputation
in such a short of time last week he
gave an interview to ABC News about the
wave of sex scandals in Hollywood no he
didn't defend sexual harassment in that
interview he didn't suggest the accusers
are lying he didn't say anything
remotely like that though you'd never
know it from the coverage which in some
cases omits any of Damon's direct quotes
so we'll let you decide for yourself
what you think of Matt Damon's views
here's what he actually said to ABC News
I do believe that that there's a
spectrum of behavior right and and we're
gonna have to figure out like what you
know there's a there's a difference
between you know patting someone on the
butt and rape or child molestation right
both of those behaviors need to be
confronted and eradicated without
question but they shouldn't be conflated
Damon went on to say this we live in
this culture of outrage and injury and
we're gonna have to correct enough to go
wait a minute none of us came here
perfect we're in this moment we're at
the moment and I hope it doesn't stay
this way the clearer signal to men into
younger people is deny it
because if you take responsibility for
what you did
your life's gonna get ruined all of that
behavior needs to be confronted but
there is a continuum and on this end of
the continuum where you have rape and
child molestation or whatever you know
that's prison that's criminal behavior
and it needs to be dealt with that way
the other stuff is kind of shameful and
gross
I don't know louis c.k I've never met
him I'm a fan of his but I don't imagine
he's going to do those things again you
know what I mean I imagine the price
that he is paid at this point is so
beyond anything that he I just think we
have to start delineating between what
these behaviors are end quote
there it is now there are a couple of
incomplete thoughts in there there's a
liner to your average publicist would
advise you against expressing in public
but ask yourself and be honest how much
of that do you actually disagree with
how much is hateful or immoral or
otherwise beyond the pale none of it
exactly there's not a single sentiment
in that entire paragraph that's not
defensible with it 90% of the American
population would find it over-the-top or
outrageous it's all within bounds or it
would have been last year but because a
handful of Twitter users don't like it
the rest of us have to pretend that Matt
Damon is somehow guilty of something
awful and if we don't pretend we may
ourselves be seen as collaborators or
whatever crimes he's supposedly
committed and forced to share his
punishment it's terrifying it's
corrupting this is how reason dies we're
watching it happen most of us are too
afraid to say anything about it as it
happens meanwhile the least reasonable
most extreme voices get louder by the
hour yesterday actress Rose McGowan
ordered the media to stop using the word
alleged when describing claims of sexual
misconduct in other words everyone
accused is guilty if you deny that
you're guilty too
weirdly almost nobody in the media
pushed back against Rose McGowan's
demand before long they may have to obey
her she has nearly a million Twitter
followers she's calling the shots let's
just be honest about what's happening
social media are driving this insanity
they're making mob justice the rule and
clear-thinking impossible large portions
of our population and ironically they
tend to be the best-educated portions of
the population are now addicted to
outrage virtue signaling bandwagoning
social media did that it turns out it's
not that helpful to know what every
famous person in America is thinking at
all times
it just makes us all crazy and less
content a few weeks ago former Facebook
president Sean Parker admitted the
website he helped found Facebook quote
literally changes your relationship with
society and with each other
Parker was right it is all shredding our
social fabric before our eyes remember
you have an absolute right to say what
you think is true other people might not
agree with you but that's okay it
doesn't make either of you evil or mean
you ought to be fired from your job
it just means you disagree that has
always been true it was true before
smartphones and no matter what they say
on Twitter it's true now joining us tile
radio show host Tammy Bruce so Tammy I
never thought that I would defend Matt
Damon and I'm not actually really
defending Matt Damon I'm just defending
the proposition that you can say
something that other people disagree
with without being fired for it and we
seem to have lost that yeah indeed look
I also love him he said some things
about the president and about others
which I which politically I very much
disagree with I don't know him but he
seems to me to be like the blind
squirrel here every now and then you
find a nut and he's found one because
he's right and you're absolutely right
in your assessment leading into this but
as a feminist here's also what I see in
this regard and I've been arguing from
the beginning here that we need to be
careful as I saw the the attempt to
conflate guys being jerks with guys who
are actual predators and if and the
women involved in this and the people on
the Left argue that well we don't want
him and others to trivialize the real
that's erat these serious allegations
but you know what really trivial
trivializes them tucker is when you do
compare a man let's say calling you
beautiful as you walk down the hallway
or maybe rubbing your back with an act
of rape that trivializes those those
survivors what they've been through and
I think that but as most people
understand that as we listen to as you
read with what Matt Damon said and this
is now our challenge because this is
what the left always does they use a
serious issue that people we know it has
to be dealt with and then write it and
then abuse it they go too far it's
almost it's like that the French
Revolution he and the people begin to do
things simply because they can and they
and they use it for revenge
or because they can't stop their rage
and then everybody's going to have to
pay Jodie Foster I think said I saw
headline the other day that every man
over the age of 30 is somewhat culpable
for the sexual harassment we now face I
have found in my life it's it's been men
who have been most helpful and the most
decent to me with women a net not
necessarily being so so this is an issue
of behavior it's not an issue about men
or or it or sex even as we know it's
about control and I think that unless we
get a handle on this and have an honest
conversation you're gonna have the left
once again shredding an important issue
like sexual harassment sexual assault
because they don't know they'd have no
boundary of what's important and then
conflating everything and then just
simply vomiting their rage out of it
exactly and it diminishes the experience
of people who really have suffered I
mean if you've lost your legs in an ie D
and I closed my hand in a car door and I
say to you we both kind of suffered in
the same way you would say no actually I
have my legs blown off you broke a
finger they're not the same yeah and
look there are different things in the
workplace and the seriousness workplace
is clearly are dealing with that but we
do have to be careful with single voices
who have perhaps originally some very
important things to say right and then
something changes in that framework
because they should not be conflated
these things are different there is a
continuum and and certain voices
hopefully voices like ours will remind
people of these things and make sure
that we don't have a wholesale
effectively a beheading of everyone who
the left doesn't like or that feminists
don't like because then we're all going
to lose that's exactly right
let reasonable people speak Tammy you
are a reasonable person thanks thank you
Sarah doing that appreciate it